littéralement impraticable à cause des
bouchons liés encore un mois la voie de
la jambette semble presque vide
aujourd'hui ce qui a changé ce sont les
accès de la zone
désormais les véhicules ne peuvent
entrer que par californie et l'autre
accès par la rn9 est réservé à la zac de
rivière hanche
d'ailleurs un peu plus bas ceux qui
veulent continuer jusqu'à jambette tombe
sur ces panneaux d'interdiction plus ou
moins respecté
nous avons eu
une multiplication du nombre de
véhicules par dix voire quinze francs on
est arrivé jusqu'à 9000 véhicules par
jour qui étaient des traversante donc
des véhicules qui n'apporte absolument
rien à la zone qui tente de gagner du
temps et qui bloque bien évidemment les
clients et qui affaiblit ces entreprises
ça c'est fini
nous avons bloqué l'accès de la zone par
la zone de rivière rouge c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un sens d'entrée
qui est le pont de californie et deux
sorties pour délester la zone depuis que
nous avons mis ça en place
les entreprises retrouvent leur
clientèle pour les entreprises
copropriétaire de la zone il était temps
de mettre fin à cette circulation
excessive qui n'intéressait pas les
commerces mais les habitudes ont la vie
dure
mais c'est quand même embêtant de faire
le tour donc eh ben on franchit l'acsel
qu'est ce que vous faites vous vous
allez dans un magasin un restaurant
attention donc je vais pas faire le tour
alsace avec vous pour verbaliser
maintenant oui la mesure à laval les
commerçants étrangler par les bouchons
pendant des semaines
les clients eux reviennent
progressivement un peu déconcerté par
ces changements
ils arrivent ils sont surpris de voir
qu'il ya deux panneaux de sens interdit
il fonce parce qu'ils ne savent pas
comment faire les gens sont perdus vous
pensez il vous le dise oui les gens sont
perdus les gens ne comprennent pas les
clients de la zone s'accoutume cependant
peu à peu au grand soulagement de cette
enseigne bio ben on constate une
amélioration de la fluidité
donc les clients commencent
progressivement à revenir on a eu deux
mois d'activités qui étaient quand même
catastrophique quoi ce qu on est à plus
de 60 % de baisse donc c'est très
difficile dans une conjoncture comme
celle-là concurrentiel donc là il s'agit
de remonter la pente
un seul accès pour deux sorties la
décision soutenue par les villes de
fort-de-france et dui lamentin et
définitive
une centaine d'entreprises et près d'un
millier de salariés espèrent rendre
ainsi la zone plus fluide et attractive